yeah  must be nice  well i noticed that kind of recently  he's been playing a lot more  aggressively  like you know he's been grabbing pawns  calculating  i remember when he played not so  aggressively at some point he was  28 30 yeah or something  in 2016. yeah he was very aggressive he  was really not aggressive but he was  just crushing everyone so i think wesley  is just very very strong  very very strong and she won yeah  lecturing he's like yeah  first move maybe e5 is more solid  it's not gonna be should be five i trade  the bishops if i already have more space  mm-hmm and then just  [Applause]  yeah  jan is actually phenomenal at lip  reading yesterday he called me out yeah  [Music]  yes